le président monsieur le ministre et le
rapporteur permettez moi et finalement
aujourd'hui l'intervention de monsieur
masson me conforte dans l'idée que cette
ppl n'avait pas lieu d'être aujourd'hui
n'avait pas lieu d'être n'avait pas lieu
d'être
parce que voilà elle stigmatise qu'elle
amène à des débats qui n'ont rien à voir
dans cet hémicycle hémicycle de la
république
la france est une et indivisible
aujourd'hui que l'on soit peu importe
donc la confession que nous avons
religieuse peu importe d'où vous nous
venons nous sommes avant tout français
et que les français nous sommes avant
d'être musulman avant d'être chrétien
avant d'être juif avant de cause de quoi
que ce soit nous sommes avant tout
français
les femmes voilées oui appartiennent à
la france elle se considère française
vous les avez sigma teasé à travers
cette ppl
vous les avez mise en accusation à
travers cette ppl
je le regrette parce qu'aujourd'hui
elles sont en souffrance
elles ont elles sont tristes et je suis
triste aussi pour elle et la république
peut l'être et c'est pour ça que j'en
appelle au premier ministre et au
président de la république pour rappeler
qu'il est le garant garant de cette paix
de juge de paix et c'est le président
qui doit rappeler que tout simplement
étiré je dirais ce n'est sifflé la fin
de la récréation
parce que nous avons donné un spectacle
qui n'est pas digne de ce qu'est la
france et de ce qu'est la république
une maman qui amène un enfant en sortie
scolaire et pâques le sien d'ailleurs
qui accompagne l'ensemble des enfants
sorties scolaires site une maman qui
veut participer justement à la
république
et si l'éducation nationale n'est pas en
accord avec cela alors l'éducation
nationale doit payer des intervenants
pour pouvoir faire le travail que
malheureusement il ne fait pas et
cliquer fait faire par ses parents
bénévoles qui ceux qui prennent du temps
tout simplement pour satisfaire le
travail pédagogique à l'extérieur de
l'établissement scolaire ne l'oublions
jamais si dans certains quartiers ces
mamans ne venait n'allait plus
accompagner ces enfants c'est aux
sorties scolaires
lior il n'y aura plus de sorties
périscolaires il faut le savoir il faut
le savoir dans certains établissements
alors je le dis au président roh tae hyo
je regrette que cette épée elle n'est
pas pu être retirés parce que je
considère qu'elle n'est pas le reflet de
la réalité de son temps en temps des
besoins aujourd'hui dans la rue parce
que on laisse la possibilité
malheureusement deux micros en âge comme
monsieur masson qui gagnera qu'on
avancera je racontais c'est terminé
merci